[Music]
all right
what's up mkbhd here and inside this
kind of huge box is possibly the most
hyped piece of tech
of this entire year and that is a
playstation 5. so this video is a look
at the final
retail packaging for this console so
some of you might know i've been testing
a preview
xbox series x this is final this is what
people who pay for it are going to get
now we get to take a closer look so
right off the bat on the front here you
see the console you see the controller
looks like this is the version with the
optical drive so good to know
and it does say 8k or 4k 120
or hdr but there's more on the back
and we're basically getting now the
whole console sideways
which i think i'm going to end up having
mine sideways we'll see
says 825 gigs up here good to know
i think you might as well open it now so
let's see
all right so at the top here
there's a little cardboard box
let's see it this is a styrofoam this is
a big
it's a big console
oh that is
pretty nice actually but it is huge
dang
that is the playstation 5. that is a
tall but also kind of nice console
[Music]
so yeah i do like this build my original
reaction to seeing the unveiling video
was more strong i think i called it like
an alien spaceship in my first
impression something like that but
seeing in person
i do kind of like it now but by the way
so in the cardboard box just to finish
off the unboxing
you've got the power cable to plug it
straight into the wall
no brick you've got one new dualsense
wireless controller which we'll get to
you got your paperwork safety guide
quick start guide
your classics and then you get an hdmi
cable and then there's this
mystery plastic thing which is actually
the dock needed to sit the ps5
flat on its side because without the
dock the ps5
it just doesn't have flat sides so it
doesn't really sit totally flat so in
any of the media you see with the ps5
sitting on the side you always see this
little black
dock underneath it that's this thing so
don't throw this out
it attaches if you want it you can you
know hide it away if you don't but
you'll probably want to have this around
if you ever switch to it sideways
someday
so all right finally seeing the ps5 in
person
a couple things strike me the size is
number one still it is gigantic
but also the textures it's a matte
finish again on the white outside part
and then the inside is very glossy as
you can see with the reflections
and actually if you look closely
really closely at the texture on the
inside of the ps5 you can see it's
actually made up of a bunch of
tiny x's o's squares and triangles
which is super cool they're extremely
small and embossed in this seemingly
random pattern
but that is super cool you can see all
the ports on the back with the heatsink
around it
power at the bottom one hdmi ethernet
and two usb and then all the way up at
the top is a kensington lock
then at the front is your full size usb
your usb type c
and then at the bottom the disk eject
button and the power button so with that
disk drive you have on the side for
physical games you do get eject buttons
still
and for the digital only version i guess
you just won't have that eject button
and the side will be blank
just cover it up there no disk drive and
yeah you can see it's it's not a
pointlessly complex design a lot of what
you're looking at up front is heat
sinks a lot of thermal management it's a
lot of cooling off
those insides size comparison time
ps4 pro it's got a dbrand skin on it but
this is the size of the console that
i've been using
it's definitely slimmer and just this
monolith oh it's heavier too the ps5 is
heavy uh and it's definitely gonna be
taller
wider it's bigger in every dimension and
it's heavier and i guess it really
depends on what underneath your tv
looks like about whether this height
difference will matter to you or not
but that height difference is real if
you're playing underneath something that
didn't have
enough clearance before airflow will be
even more restricted
because of the size of this thing xbox
series x
this one's an even more impressive
difference here
i mean the playstation just kind of
dwarfs it at this point i don't know if
that's an
efficiency thing i don't know if you're
putting it next to your tv you might not
care so much about that but
as far as just the footprint the sheer
footprint of the ps5
i think we're really seeing now how
massive this thing is kind of looks like
a
like a fancy building like a
really cool architected i don't know
what building i'm thinking of but it
kind of it kind of looks like a building
but of course there's more to the ps5
than just the console itself
there is also all the accessories let's
get into those
so inside this box you'll have a dual
sense
wireless controller if you get one
separately so it is white
so again with the stormtrooper white
color scheme with blue accents
and you notice that theme sticks through
literally everything here
so as i struggle my way through the
unboxing and get to the controller
the first impression of it is also
really nice i am a big fan
of this controller now the ps4
controller to me was fine
but i actually like the xbox elite
controller
more because it's a little bigger in my
hands it fits well it just feels higher
quality
so i was hoping actually for a bigger
more solid ps5 controller
and that's exactly what we got it's more
comfortable the stems are a little bit
longer it's a little bigger
but it is still really lightweight so
that hasn't changed but to me
yeah this controller is a pretty huge
win you can see the layout is
basically exactly the same triangle
square circle x on the right
arrows on the left trackpad in between
dual joysticks
and then around the back there's no
removable back anymore it's just a
built-in rechargeable 1500 milliamp hour
battery
and the port to charge is thankfully usb
type-c
now i'm excited to test this
controller's haptic feedback and new
improved
triggers and the responsiveness and all
that stuff but
as you can probably tell already the
embargo for today's video is
just unboxing and hardware so i can't
show that yet
but uh yeah for now the triggers are
a little more firm but anyway a couple
other things you might notice the
microphone's still at the bottom here
there's still the speaker
and the playstation button but now
there's no more led light on the back of
the controller that was like a staple of
that controller
instead the light is behind the track
pad now
and at the bottom here underneath the
light you'll notice some pins on either
side of the headphone jack
and that's for the docked charging but
we'll get more into charging
in a second but again by far the coolest
part of the design of this controller
is the texture on the back and it's
again made up of those tiny little
little shapes it's subtle but you can
see the embossed x's and o's and squares
and triangles
this is something you might honestly
never notice if you're never really
taking a super
close look at the controller but it is
there and it's giving you grip
that is a nice touch sony also made a
dual sense
charging station to charge two
controllers at once which is very smart
i've never actually had any sort of dock
for my controllers so for me they always
just kind of sit around next to the
console
plugged in by usb to charge but i think
for two controllers i'm probably going
to want to get this thing
it comes with the dock itself and then a
pretty long power cable and brick
which plugs into the bottom the
controller lines up the pins at the
bottom with the pins on the charger and
it just pops right on
and it faces upright so you can see the
charging led color behind the track pad
to know if you're done charging
or not it's great i kind of wish the
dock
was a little heavier though like it
would feel higher quality if it was a
more solid base and i could just slam
the controller in there
but the rest is great you're freeing up
usb ports on the front of the console
and if you can spare another wall outlet
for this charger seems like a good buy
also the click in is very satisfying oh
they should have done magnets though
that would have actually been kind of
sick if they had mag safe technology
in the ps5 dock you could just drop it
in there and it would line up on its own
but i don't know maybe next time okay
real quick let's also take a look at
the new headphones and the camera so the
new pulse 3d wireless headset here is
pretty distinct
this is a design that looks to be like
super minimal it's this white and black
headset for the playstation
that'll do 3d audio with certain games
that support it so they drop dual
microphones in here for better audio
quality
and noise cancellation and they promise
a 12 hour battery life
getting them out the box the headphones
themselves
they look crazy they look pretty massive
and
very unique looking so they look like
someone was challenged with the design
to make the
ultimate you know modern minimal pair of
headphones
and they came up with this now it does
have usb-c charging
great has a three and a half millimeter
headphone jack to plug straight into the
controller
and a usb dongle to connect wirelessly
to the console or pretty much anything
else
but yeah the headphones the material
here is almost entirely plastic again
which is fine
but they also have this unique dual band
design where the bottom is this sliding
rubber band
for fit sits on your head the ear
cushions are super
thick and soft and comfortable and the
whole package is pretty lightweight
so that's nice usb-c charging microphone
mute button all the controls are at the
bottom
including the sliding power and the led
indicator it's all in the left ear cup
it's really sleek and pretty cool but i
don't know
i just i feel like i'm not gonna use
these no matter how nice they make them
but maybe i'm wrong maybe do you guys
use the sony
playstation headphones or do you use
third-party headphones
or just use the speakers on your tv i'm
kind of curious
what that ratio is like maybe let me
know in the comment section below
these are cool but i probably won't use
them then last but not least
the hd camera this will probably be the
least purchased official first party
accessory but
let's be honest for people streaming
their games this is probably going to be
the camera to buy that integrates with
the whole system
and of course matches the whole
aesthetic it's a 1080p camera
it's got a built-in white stand that
lets you adjust the angle so if you put
it below the tv
you can point it up if you put it above
the tv you can point it down but yeah
there you have it
those are all the accessories that is
the playstation 5 console just a first
look
and unboxing of the hardware
conveniently thanks to the embargo that
is all i am allowed to show you
in this video today but you guys already
know as soon as i'm turning the camera
off
i'm gonna go ahead and plug it in and
fire it up and start playing some games
i mean testing i'm gonna be testing
the ps5 over the next couple weeks along
with the systems
that are all here it's tectober there's
a lot going on make sure you're
subscribed to see the full review
if you haven't already and that's about
it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace